one it's a fabulous idea to think that
the president any president would have
time enough to stop and consider
sustainability beyond the talking point
and beyond getting someone into the
cabinet that is driven in this direction
and frankly the current administration
seems to have done that on a fairly
credible scale they brought in some
caring people on that level and I think
those people have a voice certainly in
the White House there's a lot of
sustainable agricultural advocates for
what goes on with state dinners now and
things like that they're actually
thinking through food systems when they
bring them forward they're also thinking
culturally and i haven't mentioned this
but if i had the ear of anyone in
government including the president or
the Secretary of Agriculture I would say
that the culture of food is probably as
or more important than the production of
food it's something that we've ignored
in our country for a lot of reasons we
have a food science revolution that runs
parallel to the talking points that I'm
delivering right now and that food
science revolution is based on things
that we could barely recognize as food
30 years ago so I think that we have to
think about the culture of food the fact
that food actually is an important part
of our culture and not just something
that fuels the culture one way shape or
form food as fuel is a dangerous concept